hey guys it's Sam again and I just
invited a bunch of my friends over to
watch the Netflix horror film the ritual
it's super terrifying with the crazy
twist ending so let's get this thing
started I have seen the ritual and
you've seen the ritual I've seen the
ritual it's about a group of four guys
who get lost in the woods while hiking
so it's sort of like Blair Witch Project
but with the modern twist
I have not seen their ritual before but
I love horror movies I also love horror
movies and I have not seen this movie
either I'm excited newer horror films I
feel aren't as good as the old ones
slowly they're coming back I don't know
a lot about horror movies but the ones I
have seen I have a lot of reactions
what's like a non scary movie that
terrifies you you know that movie that
happening and everyone like laughs I
found it very scary paranormal activity
I couldn't be close to my closet for a
month why do you want to see something
that makes you afraid of your closet I
love it I feel like I don't want
something more close to real life
because then I'm like this could happen
to me like I babysit I couldn't be the
babysitter that oh yeah oh and then guys
I mean every person who's ever babysat
has had that fear we were hiking how can
in Sweden hiking
like some you wanting to go hiking as a
horror movie in it up those are not my
friends just hiding oh just take it lady
I don't read people's attachment to
their stuff for a wedding ring yeah but
I think his wife would be to you how
many like oh so you died because you
wouldn't give up this bit of metal yes
trying to de-escalate it's ok it didn't
work out for Batman's parents so why
would it we're gonna freeze ooh what did
you want the friend to do that's a
genuine something I would text my
friends would be like you there's a dude
inside who has like a machete just like
call the cops I would have at least
stood next to him while I was all
happening I feel like maybe I would just
grab a bunch of bottles and go for it go
I hide I feel like grab lunch bottle we
just start and then keep a couple in me
and just like go for the let's go for
the eyes and just kick regardless of
what happened in the rest of the movie I
would still be pissed at my friend if
they died and made me feel guilty to go
on a hiking trip I think that's awful
doing
it's there I don't know if it's Oh No
how did that even happen wait did he
just say break something you just like
trip everyone had yeah probably just
walk it off no no no it's my meniscus
I've done it before it we go Southwest
through here we cut the journey in half
what's really forest yeah why not little
off trail hike it could be excited might
even do is some good outfit we need this
I love how he's like it's
character-building to go through the
Uncharted forest with the guy with the
meniscus tear meniscus tear that's gonna
save our friendship I like remembering
their friend
if Jesus Christ
it's a massive deer - yeah that's not a
deer those yes simple oh look it just
started dripping what yeah it's a friend
oh yes a fresh kill
you get that tattooed on my ass okay so
like we all want to turn back we're
doing the 14 hours yeah like yeah as
soon as a friend gets injured it'd be I
okay guys like we should probably add
some that's why they're going through
the woods to get to the lodge you're
gonna go into the random house in the
woods they like just saw the haunted
emojis and they're like oh let's take
her down
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm confused as to what it is that's
witchcraft
I'd rather absolutely get soaked from
head to toe than go in that cabin I
would pitch my tent like a normal person
once again because a lone cabin in the
woods
it's never good there's either an animal
a bad person or as we saw a weird cult
situation happening and I want no part
of that at all check it out because it
could be a harmless cabin that is giving
you nice shelter this cabin didn't look
harmless from the beginning on the route
that we're going do they deserve to die
at this point yeah yeah oh my god serves
to die unless you're like me here
there's like just they need to go
they're so stupid
for the population let go
scale of 1 through 10 how scary is this
movie so far I would give it a rising
for pricing for it so hurry now I guess
potential for I agree with Emily it's at
a four but I got potential cuz it has
like little like jump scares I think
that whole thing was a scariest thing
and I thought would give it a 5 because
of that I'm out of sex I'm like legit
yeah you're sweating I feel like if I
was watching this alone it would be a
soft or software rising about like a - I
don't know I don't scare easily
yeah you're making all the decisions
when we go on our haunted hiking trip is
someone gonna die yes yes yes everyone
maybe I think - this guy's the first to
die next I keep talking about gay Jesus
why yeah he would at least maybe he's
lame in so many let's see what happens
nervous something's gonna pop and huge
what is it they have four different
tendencies together yeah they can't be
near each other they were like already
to like they're like we're in the way oh
it's a hand him that something's got to
have it right now like nightmare things
I like this weird nightmare yeah it's
kind of fun Tim are you oh you're right
yeah this insides are gonna be on the
whole hour what do we think is hunting
in the forest right now I just keep
picturing that tree thing something
that's powered by which maybe like a
golem of sorts
are we still rising so substantial the
creepiness of the dreams have like
heightened isn't it it's called the
ritual so I feel there's still a bigger
part that we're missing
yeah the ritual yeah we're gonna play a
little round of the ritual would you
rather would you rather be the lone
guilty survivor or the first person who
gets impaled I'd rather be alive I can't
even live with like if I said something
weird to someone where I'm like oh my
god did I offend them I said that they
gave me a weird look oh my god they hate
me now then I have to like journal about
it
journal did you survive survive but
everyone else wants to survive
definitely yeah diattou really yeah I
don't want to live with that I'd rather
not be the one first one to die - you
definitely want to die because you saw
your friend's dog would you rather be
stuck with these guys in the woods or
stuck in the woods with Nick Cage I just
watched a really great Nick Cage movie
the family man for the person yeah oh so
cute I would be stuck with him he was
fine as long as Dom's like there
sure yeah if you make it out and you
survived with Nic Cage that's a great
story and your friends are like this
Nick Cage and he is it Coppola so then
you're into the Coppola right it's
really ineffective running they're going
right down the middle of the hole yeah
this could be his lair
the creatures lair I just feel like I'd
be like who another person perhaps
they're off my side but clearly that's
just not the direction you're supposed
to go it's good to know they're like
real people living here very friendly
really yeah really nice looking oh oh
there's a little lady know like
modern-day hipsters like she looks like
she has purple hair another cool bolt I
drank too much conversions I feel like
this this might be the ritual seems like
you know it's crazy it's like without
contact this just looks like one of
those like Pinterest weddings you know
what I mean if you just know warmer
right it's like he's gonna bite his face
he's like I want to go out there anymore
he's like God's sake just feed it don't
make me hurt you
I would totally nailed down which I'll
do right now I would just yield to it in
hopes that I would be okay I probably do
like a combo of like fake kneeling I
think we've established very agreeable
person and would probably do well in a
cult
so yes kneel down to the monster we've
seen the entire movie now guys I want to
go through and see like what you would
rate it overall in terms of scary and
it's 1 through 10 now that you've seen
the whole thing - - as well - if I'm
watching a lone 1/8 if I'm watching with
you guys before I think that was a six
or seven for me I was like scared we
were
we jumped a lot we did yeah first time I
saw it I was so scared I give it an
eight honestly we'll go around in a
circle and pitch the bad sequel yeah
this movie I want to see like four of
whoever is the closest female friends of
theirs go and like try and kill the
demon and just play as a female movie if
it was for women this movie would have
ended like 15 minutes said and they
would have been like it would have been
in Tuscany could be at the logic
enjoying maybe having a remember when we
saw them as crazy that deer thing was
not a good thing we turned around I'm
thinking like rom-com all the wives go
on a wine trip to talk I love it
they end up being pursued by a Italian
month shape of a wide buff thanks for
joining us for spoiler party today be
sure to like the video and also comment
what movie you want to watch next
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]